you said that you know there's an idea
that men and women are equal which
you're implying that they're not
they're different
there's a difference between equality
and difference Fair difference is fair
anybody watching this right now knows
that men and women are we look
completely different right men and women
look completely different we have
different skill sets men have men have
like a third more upper body strength
than women have right there's there's a
reason why men go to war yeah there's a
reason why you know men go to war
there's a reason why we when a
transgender male competes in a female
sport he destroys and dominates with
women right like men and women are
different not fair but but fairness
that's interesting that you brought that
up now fairness is usually I find anyway
when with most people it's like well
that's not fair and it's like no men and
women are still different and that's
okay it doesn't have to be fair
like fairness in a relationship I think
is a contributor or a catalyst to the
failure of that relationship because
nothing in life is fair but but I mean
if life was fair like in your racing
career everybody would be on the podium
but no there's one through twenty on the
grid right that's how it works that's
that's how the competition ends at the
finish line but today fairness is
basically uh you know it's infused in
the fabric of society even in elementary
schools because all children are given a
participation trophy there's no first
place anymore in many sports I I mean I
agree and that's all like
there's a winner and there's a loser you
better learn the lesson when you're six
instead of when you're 36 and you're you
know miserable and your life's going
nowhere because you have no coping
skills like right learn that lesson
young
um but I think that it's just getting
stuck on that equal word like you're we
are we're equal but different is that
what you could agree to I would I would
agree with that men and women are equal
in society but we're different exactly
and in a relationship too equal but
different yeah
I'm still going to be the one that's
called upon to defend you in a
relationship when the bad guy breaks in
the house in the middle of the night and
the window smashes on the floor and you
hear a bang I'm not going to Elbow you
and say okay well you get this one
because I got the last one
I'm I'm the one that's going to jump out
of bed and put myself In Harm's Way so I
don't think that they're Fair inherently
in the way that you're describing like
you know
um you know men and women are equal and
and fair and all that sort of stuff it's
like no we're different and that's okay
I don't know that I want to apply
equality or fairness to a relationship
because it doesn't make sense to me I
wouldn't expect a woman to stand close
to the road I wouldn't expect a woman to
jump in front of somebody that was
trying to rob us right right right right
right but I I I know but I think you're
thinking that fair meaning like it's Tit
for Tat it's all you're saying equal is
yeah it's like the whole equality thing
like I don't think they were equal I
think that we're different and that's
okay but equal and importance
yes
absolutely or do you think that men get
a little bit ahead because they're the
ones that ultimately
will be the one that has to risk their
life let's say no Ben see men are the
Disposable sex women are the protected
sex that's why when the ship goes down
it's always Women and Children First I
mean it's always been that way men have
always been disposable throughout
society and women have always been
protected if if if there is Wars and by
the way we live in one of the most
peaceful times you know in human history
but if there's a war and two warring
tribes you know get together who gets
killed off all the men and when the
dominating side wins any children or or
teens that weren't either
um brought into their armies or brought
into slavery were killed off that were
male but who was protected the women and
that that's where the notion of War
Brides comes from because I mean like
even as far back as World War II War
Brides were still very very common when
the Germans invaded France and Normandy
and uh Holland and you know like all the
Dutch people sort of thing all of the
women that complied and entered the
frame of the German soldiers were
mistreated at the end of the war they
were brought out into town squares and
their heads were shaved and they were
shamed for sleeping with the German
soldiers and abandoning their you know
their families and their husbands and
things like that so women have always
been protected and brought into the
winner sort of circle and that's why
women are very adaptive in society
that's why see women don't understand
this but men have a very hard time with
breakups right we don't get it it's like
you know you know we just want to get an
answer and if you get an answer then and
you're deemed a stalker but if but if a
woman you know gets dumped then she
wants endless meetings there's emails
there's text messages she needs closure
all this sort of thing like women are
generally a lot more adaptive and they
can move on very quicker from
relationship to relationship and I think
that's because of the war bride Dynamic
where throughout history they've been
conditioned to adapt to new
circumstances and environments because
if they didn't they would die
agree with that it's true though I think
it's because women face their feelings
and emotions
because they can't help it it's part of
our nature and that men traditionally in
a breakup usually go out and start
dating someone right away or they start
they start sleeping with other people
they distract themselves and women
go through the emotions and They Mourn
and they cry and they they're miserable
and and then they they work through it
where a man's is sort of deferred or
delayed or pushed down and that never
works either what about the perspective
of vulnerability like there's such a
such a movement and culture for men to
get more vulnerable no I'm gonna guess
you think that's some right
there yeah it might have been told to be
more more vulnerable haven't they how
does it sit with you and your
girlfriends though when a guy you know
turns into a total I think there's
definitely a fine line there's a fine
line between a and a man that owns
his feelings yeah I think what you just
defined is that women like men that just
get it you know that like
you don't want to tell guys how to solve
that problem you don't want to solve the
problems for like women aren't generally
King makers they want to be with a king
you know what I mean like they want to
be with a guy that's that's got it
figured out so when it comes to that
feeling emotions or being vulnerable
your dog dies be emotional you know you
lose your parents fine be emotional it's
required you have to grieve through that
part Brenda from accounting was mean to
you today you don't want to hear about
it I mean personally for my friends if
Brenda at accounting was mad mean to one
of my girlfriends I'd be like
get over it but most women would want to
have a big conversation about that let's
get together we'll pour some wine let's
bust out the cheese get The Chicory
board going let's you know let's talk
about Brenda and what a she is
sort of thing
what about just being her
you heard
absolutely but but I mean the point that
we're making about this about this
concept is that women want men to just
get it and it's okay to be vulnerable in
certain circumstances it's okay to cry
in certain circumstances that are
warranted but most men get emotional and
get vulnerable and cry over the littlest
things which turn women off you know men
don't understand this that they want
women want men that just get it that are
competent that can solve problems that
can get things done that can make it
rain they don't want to deal with a
crybaby you know one of the things you
hear a lot of women say and um you know
after I got divorced I was dating a lot
of divorced women as well because I was
you know looking at women around my
stage same age group and one of the
questions I was always asking so why did
you get divorced so what happened and I
heard a lot of oh you know he was a big
baby you couldn't keep a job down he was
such a he wasn't a man he was a
big beta you know big cry baby you know
like all of these things and it's like
oh that's interesting but who was the
guy that you marry worried right like
you know did something change and one of
the things that happens to men in
long-term relationships I've noticed is
it's the betaization through a thousand
concessions you see what I'm saying so
it starts with something like hey Rich
you know don't brush your teeth over
there you're going to get toothpaste on
the carpet then it goes to make sure you
put the white socks in the white hamper
and the black socks and the black camper
then it goes that one just makes sense
let's go vegan together
and then it's and then it continues to
go concession after concession after
concession sure sure and the and the
thing is is that women truthfully they
don't want men to make that many
concessions I understand the organized
part like I understand you know the
laundry thing and all that sort of stuff
but as soon as you start stamping
everything yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes and then you give her the stamp
and she starts stamping everything yes
her interest in that guy declines
dramatically agreed because here's the
deal he doesn't know who the he is
right and you why is it like a girl to
not know who the she is either like
don't you want a girl to contest with
every now and again don't you want a
little bit of a challenge there's a
perfect ratio of disagreements that need
to happen in a relationship and you know
I don't know what your thoughts are in
Jordan Peterson but he'll talk about
that too you don't want it easy you want
some level of challenge that is required
for the relationship to be strong you
don't want to push over do you do you
have a pushover girl I I don't want to
come home to a disagreeable bossy
woman I want to come home to a loving
woman
of course a woman wants a loving man but
you don't you you can't tell me that you
do you want a woman to make a thousand
concessions for you and that you'd still
respect her
I would
for what
because she's not a man
and women are different remember that
you know we talked about that before men
and women are different just because you
want see I think the great lie that a
lot of women have subscribed to when
they're drunk on this Kool-Aid is
they've been told to behave like men oh
you have to be somewhat disagreeable you
have like there's a certain ratio
because Jordan Peterson that's not true
that's not true
is it not true that's just called
autonomy
is it though yeah absolutely because no
two people are identical right but it's
not like we could all just agree on
everything so just like you're gonna
know who you are and I would know who I
was like you're not always going to
agree so you can respectfully disagree
or you can have the discussion change
your mind perhaps I actually like part
of doing this interview is I was hoping
you could change my mind on some things
because I think because then I know I've
learned something
because I'm I'm open-minded that's
that's like the fascination is that cool
teach me something new but I know I have
my convictions about myself I know who I
am and I'm not just going to bend over
in every single category so a man can
feel good about himself or so he cannot
be challenged yeah but believe it or not
it's he's not he's not trying to feel
good about himself by not arguing with
you he just doesn't want to argue with
you he just wants peace in his life
right now I get that not many men are
competent and deserve a peaceful life I
understand that there's a lot of losers
out there a lot of weak men that get
challenged by women for a reason I get
it I fully understand that but a guy
like me I I don't want a confrontational
woman in my life right it's it's not
needed and it's unnecessary and I'm I'm
competent enough and I'm successful
enough and influential enough that I
don't need to put up with that sort of
thing so while I get that a lot of women
have told have been told to be strong
and independent and decisive and you
know to some agree like women I think
today are more disagreeable than they
ever have been in history yeah but I
don't think that it's because we're
being told to it's because we are it's
because people are getting more
confident with who they are
well it's because women don't need men
anymore nobody needs anybody
don't they do they I don't know that's a
great question if you like this clip and
you want to hear the whole episode click
at the bottom of your screen